and if you have a minute anybody has a
minute to step outside and just take a
look at the skies
we only have a handful of high clouds
around
as we're looking you can see that they
are really bringing some nice color
to our early wednesday morning sky it's
beautiful out there now we're going to
get
more high clouds as we get through the
morning in the afternoon
but right now it's just a few out there
just as that early morning light is
bending over the horizon
lots of 30s to the south valley in the
south valley and them at 34
and over to the southwest mountains edge
at 37 nellis
on the east you're 35 degrees this
morning freezing in prom
north winds plaguing the colorado river
valley today wow 55 degrees
only because those strong north winds
are stirring up the mercury chilly start
out at red rock too at 31 degrees
high pressure over the intermountain
west steering yet
another very wet potent winter storm
up into the pacific northwest so here
comes that batch of high clouds
we'll still call we're still going to
stay very very dry more clouds tonight
and those will be a little bit heavier
than what we're seeing through the day
today 61 degrees
sunny start afternoon high clouds we'll
call it mostly sunny clouds tonight and
then we'll still see mostly sunny skies
to finish the week
very mild 60s all the way into saturday
cold front will cool us off a little bit
breezy winds on sunday and we're right
back to mild 60s again
next week